dude your boy last night at the comic
store ridiculous night the lineup was so
[ __ ] stupid ly ridiculous I'm getting
ready to leave right Rogan pulls in he's
like don't go anywhere I was gonna get
my car microts up he he gets it and this
is hashtagged all homo he gets out of
his car he's buying that carnivore diet
he had a a [ __ ] spelt spelt trimmed
black shirt on yeah
about carnivore diet he just had a look
at the Harris Sam Harris see I'm here
now you a smart guy and he gets a scar
was Tom Cruise I was a you talk ruse
he looked unbelievable I went hold on I
go dude you look unbelievable in every J
way possible yeah you look unbelievable
right now and what are you doing it was
just carnivore I think well I get on
carnival now I'm going Carver because
he's that's rude I'm sure I've never
seen you like this
unbeliev I was like what the [ __ ] are
you doing do he was Carter I feel great
and a lot of people talk [ __ ] I hears I
feel great man I've never seen him look
better his skin was gone she yet there's
a skin looks he had this this this
trimmed [ __ ] black button-up shirt
that was that was tailored Wow I think
this is the best you've ever lived dude
well maybe Brian should I'm not eating
any more [ __ ] sugar
I'm only eating I needs a little kick in
the ass but I get I got to go the gross
store and line it up otherwise I'll just
start today what today's last day
starting money to go tally nope I'm not
doing it you don't need to do it you
look good you know what's going on Rogan
look and then Jeselnik he comes out of
yo dude you've lost a ton of weight he
goes stop drinking stop eating sugar
stop being carbs dude down 20 pounds
going on when he come in looks like a
[ __ ] supermodel but everybody's
tightening us happening I'm the
shittiest looking one here well we're
tightening up a little bit tighten up
people a little older than you are too
so what happens is they go I got to
start tightening up I know right oh yeah
start now though I'm not arresting look
better all the years I've known as a
holy [ __ ] it's really sad sorry I said
the other day I go your skin looks very
glowy and smooth again in every gay way
power
was like did you [ __ ] ridiculous yeah
yeah it was insane it's so distracting
and then so check out the lineup E right
Sam
goes on then I go then
Whitney Joey Diaz Dave Attell and then
Chris D'Elia yeah that's a hotel just
jumps on thanks again I mean this guy in
the world
oh my but the funniest guy in the world
I think so yeah he had nothing so so
hard in the back this so hard Evaristo
back he had his bag like three good
treats you know you're back in the green
room I want Bobby Lee outside but after
me and went Bobby Whitney Joey a tell me
Chris talk about getting your money's
worth
oh yeah so tells back then he doesn't
really know everybody's like kind of
talking to Whitney telling everybody is
this bag of treats and he goes I'm going
on soon uh you got like pink room he's
was I'm just I'm just gonna put this
back here they see him look at me and
that that Craig guy is there and just
some other you know like saying guys
they just oh just anybody here his
stand-up is I mean I've I've never seen
anything like it
well he's like I've and and it can be
he's go yeah you'll see him he's the
Comics comic when he does ten about all
of us remember we all walk all left the
Great Wall the comics let the green went
to the side I'm always seem to have the
master try something store yeah I every
comic stop what they're doing walked out
and watched the town now destroy but I
thought of you last night you appreciate
this because I remember a long time ago
you and I were doing we did like Howard
Stern's wrap-up show and we're doing
that with those guys and I didn't say
much and Brian just took over did his
thing we at Don's I did I'd say [ __ ]
anything and you're like dude you don't
have to say anything sometimes less is
more
yeah I was on and you just were you
bouncing off me you don't have to be the
center like you don't have to be in
sometimes just good it goes further to
be quiet so last night we're all like
hanging out it tells doing his things
Whitney it's Bobby the Lea wrote
everyone's in the circle and I didn't
say anything
I tell Jojo you're quiet huh
the guy I'm sucking up man I wanted I
have nothing to offer you guys right I'm
just soaking it sure I'm shouldn't be
talking now I just want to soak this
that's great to do that I thought
everything wrong with I said I'm soaking
up man I'm soaking sometimes that's so
micro print yeah it's a great that's a
great lineup right there
yeah man I think that's very appropriate
and you can learn so much at L you got
to remember the first time I saw tell
the I think Time magazine said here are
the group of young people shaping our
golf culture oh wow and Dave Attell was
featured one of the features in that you
were young young comedians this was
1992-93 uh and he and patty Jenkins and
I when we went and watched because she
said I want you to start doing Stan so
we went to a comedy club and she taught
me to do it she's the reason I do stand
it and I went and watched David tell
that's right
so that's right that's confusing I
wouldn't watch David tell greg Giraldo
Charisse honey oh jeez Louise CK please
come back this is what this was the one
just getting going but they were all
monsters then and Dave Attell was as
funny then as he is today and I'm not
exaggerating I was so astonished first
of all that whole line because they were
all killing me and I was gonna get into
stand-up and I was the funny guy in my
group and I went patty said stop biting
your nails she said stop biting your
nails I was biting my nails because I
was so overwhelmed I couldn't even laugh
you know when you're that overwhelmed
you can't laugh you're you're just so
you're sewing off taking it in
you're just an awful lot it's it's a
form of power where you just can't stop
looking at them and you're like how do
you how does a human being do that how
do i I could never come close to that
it's just overwhelming this is too much
and it's what happened I I just couldn't
speak and I was only I had my body when
asked I was so anxious and so
overwhelmed with I guess ocean really
yes yes the beauty the beauty of human
beings when they're at their best and
comedy when it's done like that and when
you see a lineup like that in 1993 and
remember there wasn't a way to really
make money you had
do clubs I don't even think there was
very little touring there were clubs but
it wasn't nearly like it was Vegas act
you were a New York guy yeah you did
comedy in clubs and made where you could
I just stayed quiet cuz you know tell
literally is a goat and so he was
talking just the nuances and like the
details he was talking about someone
asked him out shooting a special inside
the main room and he was going through
like what how many seats you take out
for the cameras here and the shot over
here and you're just like yeah this why
I went shootin yo are and just you're
like holy yeah you're talking about a
guy I didn't say a word
yeah thirty years and say word 30 years
in didn't say a word yeah and been
crushing rooms for 30 years like I mean
but even that's still what was cool as
he went back then he sees Sammy and Sam
cuz you can go on after Joey or Whitney
or Bobby he's like whatever you want man
and he was kind of crowd is it though
you know just like yeah every comic
right cut crowd is it I thought be a
different each time I he's like duh okay
well I feel like I'm gonna field out and
he's I depend on the comments to
depending what I do so he goes out there
and gets to tell you just yeah well
what's funny about mastery in your life
is that there are different schools of
thought like one is the idea that well I
can do a bunch of things well and then
there's another school thought which is
I'm gonna do one thing really well and
if I really get good at that
I'll figure out the rest that's guys
that's what he'll and then life isn't as
much a mystery because you're gonna it's
gonna require all of you and it's gonna
require you to take into account so many
things like when Michael Jordan was
speaking about Kobe yeah Kobe would call
him three in the morning and ask him
about different post how to post up in
fortunes process and and ask him Michael
Jordan that question and Michael's are
[ __ ] dumb questions but he wanted to
know the details the minutiae and
there's something that's that that's
very very beautiful about to us and now
you saying that I wish you would wipe
the cookie off your shirt me nuts
okay about the details yeah let's
continue details but you know some
details get it but to your point do you
remember when I told that sir how Mark
Munoz asked me to speak to those guys
because they weren't show up to pack
yeah so home
I'm Tony go home I know kids who are
obsessed with this they're calling me at
3:00 and more in their claw mark that's
the best advice you could've given us go
home wait don't waste your time here
same thing with comedy there's there's
some of these guys we know who they
and you know it's mijeong guys like like
Chappell Lacey or you're open or the
Terrell AC dude I'm talking doing three
four sets at night
he's audition for Netflix show he's
hustling dude yes I know that guy yeah
and then there's other guys that we know
like I might do a set this week I'm like
oh what's that Papa you're competing
with these guys over here map so they
give a kid who emceed for me at the
make-a-wish I was listening to him that
was his dream that was his wish he
wanted he wanted nobody want to get in
stand-up he's done but i i've listened
to him and I realized he wasn't working
he wasn't right he wasn't performing a
lot I could tell
been doing this too long well you came
upstairs and he knew and he said what do
you think you get a chance to hear my
set and I said yeah he said he just
looked at me he goes I should ride more
huh I go what do you think I just let
him says he and I wanted to feel bad a
little bit because the only way he's
gonna change if he feels like [ __ ] you
slap another good faith I didn't say
anything
you slap him like I did I said believe
in slap words you just take I heard the
penguin now I'm gonna slap him a
slightly stupid [ __ ] face in the
slide don't you remember this moment you
don't get to be on stage with me because
there are too many great people over who
work really hard who get to be on stage
so you don't get to do that you don't
get to do that and so I wanted him to
feel bad because he should feel bad and
and if he wants this then he's got to
get it if he doesn't get out of here
it's okay but it's not for you you want
to be you want to be you know to
dilettantes a dilettante is somebody who
dabbles in this in and what they do
no I know because I party I am buddy
call just call could I embody the hold
on know how is this it's about just kung
fu kung fu' what you're saying Golf well
that's how it's said so as I'm from I
studied in China pistol